[Música]
Hola esta es la crónica de medio
ambiente de France 24 y yo soy María
Clara calle
los cortes de luz son cada vez más
duraderos en Sudáfrica Aunque es uno de
los países más ricos del continente
enfrentan problemas de energía desde
2007 el año pasado los apagones se
duplicaron y en lo que va de 2023 han
alcanzado un nivel sin precedentes Y es
que la energía se va en ocasiones
durante 10 o 12 horas la situación es
tan delicada que el gobierno decide el
rama fosa declaró estado Nacional de
desastre
el Centro Nacional de gestión de
desastres ha clasificado
Consecuentemente la crisis energética y
su impacto como un desastre
por lo tanto declaramos el estado de
desastre nacional
para responder a la crisis eléctrica y
sus efectos
la declaración le permite al gobierno
que lugares como hospitales o plantas de
tratamiento de agua no se queden sin luz
entre otras medidas pero el problema de
fondo no se soluciona y es que la razón
principal de los apagones por más de una
década es la compañía Estatal scom que
provee el 95% de la energía que consumen
los casi 60 millones de habitantes la
comisión que dirigió El juez Raymond
sondo descubrió en 2022 que la junta
directiva estuvo involucrada en
corrupción además la empresa utiliza
plantas de energía basadas en carbón y
gran parte de su infraestructura es
obsoleta el dinero que recauda scom es
insuficiente para renovarla pues desde
los tiempos de la parte de la compañía
subsidiaba la mayor parte de la
electricidad de las grandes industrias
ya que la energía se suministraba solo a
una minoría blanca y el legado de los
precios bajos continuó una de las
soluciones es transitar a energías
limpias pues hasta ahora dependen
altamente del Carbón este combustible
fósil provee más del 70% de la
electricidad que se consume en el país
muy por encima de otras fuentes como el
gas natural la energía nuclear o las
hidroeléctricas y ni siquiera comparable
con el 1% que representan las energías
como la eólica o la solar el problema es
que el carbón es el combustible fósil
más contaminante de hecho en el ranking
mundial Sudáfrica ocupa el puesto número
14 de los países que más gases de CO2
emiten por eso una transición energética
es una vía también para lograr la
neutralidad de carbono que es con
prometió a 2050 por eso el presidente
insiste
tion continuaremos nuestra transición
justa hacia una economía baja en carbono
a un ritmo que nuestro país pueda seguir
y ese ritmo que podamos pagar y
garantizar de alguna manera la seguridad
energética
emprenderemos nuestra transición justa
de una manera que abra la posibilidad a
nuevas inversiones a una nueva
industrialización y sobre todo a nuevos
puestos de trabajo
pero veamos en detalles estas promesas
que no son nuevas en el presidente
ramafosa el primer gran proyecto con el
que el mandatario intentó reducir los
cortes de Luz fue con el plan integrado
de recursos de 2019 que pretendía
aumentar la capacidad eléctrica del país
con energía eólica y solar además
prometía desmantelar varias centrales de
Carbón a 2030 en 2020 se creó un
programa que le daba el aval a
productoras independientes para que
generaran energía por fuera del sistema
de scom y en julio de 2022 Rama fosa
lanzó el plan de acción energética con
el que levantaba el umbral de licencias
y flexibilizaba todavía más la
producción privada también le apostaba a
mejorar el rendimiento de las
energéticas que tenía scom si bien para
2023 todos estos esfuerzos lograron
aumentar un poco las energías limpias a
hoy sigue siendo mínima frente al carbón
de hecho mientras el gobierno insistía
en una transición energética también
desarrolló dos nuevas centrales
eléctricas de Carbón llamadas medupi y
cusile que siguen siendo una fuente
principal de energía además el gobierno
pretendía abrir una adicional llamada
tabamzi en la que la empresa francesa
engine quería invertir sin embargo en
diciembre de 2020 el tribunal superior
de pretoria tumbó el proyecto
argumentando que iba a ser uno de los
más contaminantes del mundo
así mientras Sudáfrica prometía energías
limpias reforzaba el carbón a pesar de
ser víctima de la crisis climática menos
de una semana después de declarar estado
de desastre por la crisis energética el
presidente ramafosa impuso un estado
nacional semejante pero por inundaciones
de hecho dos de las cuatro veces que se
ha utilizado esa figura ha sido por
desastres naturales el primer estado de
desastre fue en marzo de 2020 a causa de
la pandemia del covid 19 luego Se
repitió en abril de 2022 para agilizar
la respuesta gubernamental frente a las
inundaciones en coazul luna natal que
mataron a más de 450 personas y en lo
poco que va de 2023 la medida se ha
decretado dos veces una para la crisis
energética y otra para las más recientes
inundaciones el fenómeno de la niña está
golpeando con fuerza a siete de las
nueve provincias sudafricanas las más
afectadas son humalanga y cabo Oriental
que Walker la región que más padeció las
inundaciones del 2022 están ubicadas en
el sureste del país y no es una
coincidencia pues todas quedan sobre el
océano Índico y los científicos señalan
que como este Se está calentando por las
emisiones contaminantes atrapadas en la
capa de ozono las lluvias son más
fuertes es así como la contaminación que
produce Sudáfrica es en parte
responsable de las lluvias torrenciales
que padecen a pesar de esto el país
continúa con su producción de Carbón
mientras los apagones y las inundaciones
son más frecuentes hasta aquí La Crónica
de medio ambiente vean más en franjas
veinticuatro punto com
[Música]